hey everybody it's Mike from
immortalflows and welcome to today's
video today is uh Tuesday January 24th
2023 and it's kind of quiet day in the
markets and you know I was looking
through some of the comments this
morning
um yesterday's videos and what I there
was a question on there which you know
this is sort of the the whole point of
today's video is
um you know how can markets rise on
aggressive selling right because
technically under aggressive selling
shouldn't the market be selling off and
you know that's what I'm going to
address today so again you know just
really briefly if you enjoy my videos be
sure to subscribe to the channel and you
know if you find you get some value be
sure to like the videos so I'm going to
be showing you the example in
U.S bonds right 30-year bonds we're
using a four range chart here because
you know I like to use range-based
charts on bonds because you know they
tend to be quite slow moving at times
and you know if you're using a minute
based chart it's going to be a little
bit difficult to understand what's
happening in the order flow since
there's not a lot of uh price movement
in certain times of the day right and
you know when you're looking at order
flow you also want to take into account
the movement of the market right just
not seeing a big order hitting the
market and on trying to understand its
effect on the market you're looking at
sort of the cumulative effect of the
orders coming into the market all right
so today in the bonds there's a perfect
example right that's that's why when I
was I saw the questions and I was
watching the bonds today I thought you
know hey this would make a great uh
a great example in the video so you can
see the bonds moving up right we hit our
low today 129.16 you know just before
nine o'clock and then we started putting
in this rally all the way up to the high
of the day
and on this move up
we're seeing aggressive selling that's
taking place right well how do I know
it's aggressive selling well
on the surface the most easiest way to
tell is by looking at the Delta right
the Delta is the net difference between
the aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in the bar basically the volume
that's traded on the bid the volume
that's traded on the offer now
on most footprint charts I mean like my
footprint chart that I use regularly I
have just a Delta Max Delta Min Delta
cumulative Delta Delta volume and the
bar's volume you could actually you know
a lot of the software's out there I know
mine offers it is you can actually see
what the actual volume was that traded
on the bid and the actual volume traded
on the offer so I'm just going to throw
that up here so you know it just gives
us an idea
of what's taking place here so I'll just
give it a second here so I'll just add
it go into the summary content add the
ask volume add the mid volume okay so
ask is volume is going to be the first
line bid volume is going to be the
second third one is the Delta so as you
can see here right on the low the Delta
is 701 it's a positive Delta right so
that volume traded on the offer is 25.53
the volume traded on the bid was 1852.
that difference is 701 it's a positive
number because more volume traded on the
offer meaning that
25 53
2553 contracts traded on the offer that
were aggressively bought
versus
1852 sold into the bids there in this
bar and the net difference 701 it's a
positive difference because there's more
volume traded on the offer is telling me
there's more aggressive buyers Market
moved up that's what you expect to see
right then the next bar positive Delta
of 51. and this time is a little bit
closer right the volume traded on the
ask was 1591 the volume traded on the
bid was 1540 so 1 591 contracts traded
on the offer side in this bar versus
1540 was traded on the bid side meaning
there was 1540 contracts sold into the
bids versus
1591 contracts bought at the offer
okay so what you're measuring is the
aggressiveness in the bar right the
aggressive buying you know people
crossing the bid offer line people that
were either working bids that went up
and bought the offer
or people that just came in and bought
at the market that is the volume on the
ask
the volume on the bid is people that
were probably working an offer and sold
into the bid they got tired of waiting
and sold it into the bid they crossed
the bid offer line or people that are
just coming in and hitting the bid
immediately okay
so the next bar also a green candle okay
so we got green candle positive Delta
green candle positive Delta now all of a
sudden we've got green candle negative
Delta minus 95.
what's going on right
you have negative Delta so you have more
aggressive sellers
selling into the bid then buying the
offer yet the market is still going up
what gives
well let's go over the math again so
what you have is 18 38 1838 contracts
bought on the offer
1933 contracts sold into the bid okay
giving you a difference of minus 95
there was 95 more contracts sold into
the bid then bought from the offer right
giving you this negative Delta now you
know granted 95 it's not a huge amount
it's you know it's 95 contracts it could
be
a difference of one or two trades you
know this this bar could have just you
know late buying could have come in I
mean there could have been some decent
selling early late buying came in you
know when I see relatively small Delta
is like 51.95 I kind of treat it as
neutral
but right now it's negative negative 95
and what is going on well let's look at
the volumes right you can see at 26
there was 729 contracts traded
when it was bid there versus 581 when it
was offered
at 25 there's 501 traded on the bid
versus 434
when it was offered at 24
it was 649 traded on the when it was bid
there versus 254 when it was offered so
what you're starting to see is some
signs of support bidders coming into the
market that are starting to absorb that
aggressive selling that's coming into
the market and this is how markets go up
on aggressive selling because even
though you have the aggressive selling
you got to still realize
what's meeting it well passive buying is
meeting it it's passive buying is it's
stepping up to absorb that aggressive
selling that's why the market is not
going down
is because you have bidders in here
passive buyers that are happy to be
buying it at these levels right the
selling is coming in because remember
right markets don't go up because
there's more buyers than sellers markets
don't go down because there's more
sellers and buyers for every buyer
there's a seller in the market
but when you start
thinking about passive buyers and
passive sellers in addition to just the
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
that's the difference that order flow is
going to give you in your analysis as
opposed to just regular following price
because now you're adding into it that
element of volume that's traded on the
bid the element of volume traded on the
offer and you know whether it's strong
or not then the next bar another green
candle okay
and you got positive Delta okay that's
what you expect to see right you know we
had that one bar with the negative Delta
here but green green Green right
positive Delta positive Delta positive
Delta the one bar with negative Delta
okay
but look what you have in this bar you
have a selling imbalance 1774.
okay so when you're looking at
imbalances you're looking at the
imbalance in the two-way auction when it
was 28 bit at 29
1774 traded on the bid versus only 320
on the offer that is a selling imbalance
more than four to one I use a ratio of
four to one you determine my imbalance
is traded in this two-way auction just
as here one tick below when it was 27.28
you had 347 only traded on the bid at 27
versus I'll show you at 20
this is 27 versus 1884 trading on the
offer at 28. so you have a buying
imbalance here then you have a selling
imbalance here so what is actually
taking place okay so while the markets 7
8 you know it's trading eights trading
eights and then it turns eight bid so
not only did it you had that aggressive
buying taking place at eight here at 28.
once it turned 8 bid there was a strong
bid coming into the market basically
absorbing whatever selling there was now
at 28 before there was a there was
passive sellers at 28
now you have strong passive buyers at 28
that are sitting here absorbing all that
selling that's coming down now this bar
still had the positive Delta because
there was still more volume being traded
on the offers at the different price
levels in this bar but let's take a look
at the next bar
another green candle got a strong
negative Delta minus 274.
and it's trading higher
okay so in this move you've had one from
the bartholo one two three four five
bars two of them have negative Delta
okay let's take a look at the volumes
well here volume traded on the offer at
the ask is
3258 volume that was traded into the bid
the aggressive selling into the passive
buyers was
3532 giving you a difference of minus
274 so you actually had more aggressive
selling in this bar you had minus 274
274 more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers in the bar yet the bar
went up okay well why did it do that
well why why did the bar go up meaning
you had the aggressive sellers there
when it was at 130 even okay
there was 23.94 contracts traded on the
bid
but you had a lot of selling coming into
that bid right when it was even bid at
01 everyone is selling it thinking I
can't go any higher you know this this
line here is is the opening price you
know which is you know it is a level for
for a lot of Traders the opening price
you know hanging around basically
unchanged you know they're happy to sell
it because you know for whatever reason
you know maybe they're thinking well you
know we have just our normal
distribution day this is probably right
around you know where the value was I
haven't pulled up a value a volume
profile but it's probably where the POC
was for the day so you have a lot of
aggressive selling coming in there
but you have strong buyers you got more
people bidding
than aggressively buying then once those
aggressive sellers
had you know once their bullets ran out
and they got no more contracts to sell
then the market starts ticking higher
that's what causes it to go up it's not
going up because you have aggressive
sellers it can't you get more aggressive
selling so once that aggressive selling
stops
that then the market starts going up
right and you see it's going up it's not
a heck of a lot of volume
um you know 72 contracts you know you
got the 37 then the next bar is the doji
bar opens it closes you know basically
at the same level but still a nice
negative Delta minus 400 it's actually
one of these candles where it traded
down and then closed up again okay but
again minus 424 Delta the volume that
was bought on the offer
was just
2283 2283 versus the volume sold into
the bid of 2707.
okay and again you know this bar so you
know the bar it was starting to sell off
it was looking like a nice big red bar
but what happened once those aggressive
sellers
ran out of bullets
you don't that's selling pressures
removed from the market the market ticks
back up in this case you don't really
have you know a the selling and balance
like you had here the 1774 against 320
or the 23 94 against 288
um here it's kind of evenly distributed
for the most part the only areas that
sort of out is um
you know this 923 this is just a shade
more on the bid side than the offer side
but it's you know spread out over four
levels
then the next bar another green candle
positive Delta okay you know sort of
what you expect so here you've had one
two three four five six seven bars of
which one two three have had negative
Deltas now you're on the eighth bar
negative Delta minus 180. volume bot
aggressively volume traded on the offer
at the ask 1344 volume sold into the bid
1524 giving you a negative Delta of
minus 180 but you still have a green
candle
well why you got 843 here at 10 traded
on the bid versus 299 on the offer right
that was enough volume coming in here to
absorb whatever aggressive selling was
taking place to arrest this move from
dropping lower in this bar now again
remember these are range bars these are
not minute based charts okay so it's
based on price movement
then the next bargain another doji bar
open and closed at the same level
positive Delta 549 okay now we're still
going up next Bar Green candle
big negative Delta minus 309
got that imbalance 10 29 1029 against 41
this imbalance is coming in at 13.
okay
you're starting to see the pattern here
right what's happening here is you got a
strong bidder to absorb whatever
aggressive selling so this Market went
up
obviously there was aggressive buying
right that's what's going to move you
know removing the next offer and the
next offer and the next offer is what
causes it the market to go up but what
stops it from going down
is the support of buying the passive
bidders coming in for size you know the
729 the 500 the 649 the 1774 the 2300
the 1000 the 900 you know the 600 the
800 the 1061 the 1029 that's why this
Market is not selling off you do have
aggressive selling but it's being
absorbed by strong passive buyers
and then we went up to new highs okay
but
it was pretty evident I mean you're not
going to see it down here or here it's a
little vague at this point you start
seeing it grow a bit more here even
though you got the
positive Delta you know the the clue is
one is obviously this negative Delta but
again it's kind of small it's not you
know it's not minus 450 it's just minus
95.
this should get your interest up and
then by the time you get to this bar you
know so it's a decent move I mean I'm
not saying yeah you would have bought it
down here no you wouldn't because you
still got the positive deltas
but when you start seeing this folding
you can see the bitters just coming into
the market it's clear as day look at
this volume trading right here on this
side 729 51 649 1774 2300 900 1000 this
is your clue this is I think the area
where a lot of people sort of click with
them that hey you know what this
Market's got that support of buying that
we need to absorb whatever aggressive
selling is coming in and then we had
this nice March up and it happened
pretty quick right it happened this bars
up until 9 56. so about 30 minutes
went from
130.01 all the way up to 21.
and you're still getting that support of
mine coming in here here even here as
you're making the new highs
and I mean look at this move from we got
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve bars from low to
the high
how many bars with negative Delta one
two three four five six half of the bars
you don't see any red bars in here on
this move up so it's a nice beautiful
move up
without any pullbacks but you still see
that negative Delta you still see that
aggressive selling so even though you
have that aggressive selling I mean
every bar is going to have aggressive
selling there wasn't there would just be
all zeros here but what you have is
absorption right you have people that
are bidding the market to absorb
whatever aggressive selling is taking
place
as the market is moving up that's what
you like to see on a move now in some
markets it's going to be difficult to
see you know if if you're trading a thin
thinly traded Market you know where it's
a lot of zeros or one twos and threes
it's not as clear takes a you know a
little bit more experience to to
understand what you're looking at but
you know on markets that trade a lot of
volume obviously bonds tends it's it's
clearer to see that's why I use the
bonds as an example so I hope you guys
understand it now
um
I forgot the username that brought up
the question but you know
that's how the market can go up on
aggressive selling even though it's not
going up necessarily on the aggressive
selling is going up on the passive
buying that is absorbing the aggressive
selling the aggressive selling is there
right there's always aggressive buying
and aggressive selling in every bar
but when you generally when you talk
about aggressive selling taking place
you think the market is going down here
you have aggressive selling taking place
that's been absorbed by the strong
passive buyers right the people that are
working bids
passive sellers would be people working
offers okay so in this case it's going
up because people are just catching
whatever selling is taking place because
you know their view of the market is
markets going up all right guys I'll end
it there so hope you enjoyed this video
be sure to subscribe to the channel and
hit the like button if you got some
value out of it and keep those comments
coming bye bye